Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a for you because every
person that comes a step closer to Allah
through your donation you will in be
reaping a reward click the link and
donate what you
can brothers and sisters and dear
friends as you guys know the horrific
attack that took place on a Christmas
celebration where the German people were
celebrating wherever it is for that
matter every non-muslim whoever that
whoever that is Islam they have a right
to celebrate what they want to celebrate
in the Islamic rule when Christians and
Jews live under Islamic rule they have
their churches they have their
celebration whatever it is they can
drink alcohol they can do whatever they
like because they are protected by the
Islamic Khalifa So this notion that
Muslims are against it or if we had
opportunity when I'm driving and I'm or
have great urge to just run over people
because they cting Christian is absolute
nonsense now very bizarrely is really
bizarre and we I need you guys to help
me report Sky News to ofcom here is why
listen very carefully to to what they
are saying because they're in utter
shock how could it be how could it not
be a Muslim it has to be a Muslim uh no
they're not yeah there's a lot of crazy
people and majority of them are not
Muslim for that matter yeah here's the
uh news that they did they little STP up
and let's see what they said the Target
and brutal method of the Christmas
Market attack bear the Hallmark of
islamist terrorism oh yes the Hallmark
they they call and they look and they're
like I can smell islamism in the air
Halal I can smell Halal in the air yes
yes what the hell are you on about I
don't what does what does this mean but
anyways let's let's carry on it's an
atrocious attack that happened and many
people Killers Mass murderers terrorists
whatever you want to call it they all
have the same method the methodology the
same the whole Mark is what they want to
kill innocent people there's not a
specific label given to specific
religion for it okay let's carry on but
the suspect is described by German
authorities as an
islamophobe at this point we say for
sure that the perpetrator was evidently
islamophobic we can confirm that
everything else is a matter for further
investigation and we have to
wait okay so it's like it's like they're
disappointed but but the bus is what you
know he he he was was an islamophobe
it's like they they're like oh man
bloody Ru my night now you know it's
islamophobe Oh's he's an islamophobe how
could it be it's not possible but listen
a little bit more closely guys look what
she says unbeliev and we need you guys
to report this present CER and Sky News
to offc come because this is biased
media bias coverage now under arrest the
suspect has been named in German media
as Talib a a 50-year-old doctor from
Saudi Arabia who fled to Germany almost
two decades
ago regarding the motive of the
perpetrator I can say it currently looks
like he was dissatisfied with how Saudi
refugees were treated in Germany and
that could have been the motive I mean
there's been people saying yes okay he's
not a Muslim but still the the the the
the Arab region the Arab they have this
uh animosity against Christmas what are
you on about course most Arab countries
they have Christmas celebrations there
what are you talking about yeah okay so
um that's absolutely nonsense it's like
as if they're like no if it's not Muslim
it's an Arab thing it's if it's not Arab
it's a black if it's not the black it's
a brown it's not if it's not them it's
the Russians it's just the other no
German police were seen on Friday night
searching a house in a nearby town in
connection with the attack they'll also
be trolling the suspect's online
presence on social media he described
himself as an ex-muslim who helps people
flee the gulf that's very clear he also
was a Zionist atheist ex-muslim very CL
spotted the ADF party or whatever is in
Germany which is a far right party he
was Far Right himself he was he had more
in common with Tommy Robinson he had
what in common with a p animous weasel
the cursed face individual yes and the
funny is I I saw a clip
of weel yeah he's like no you know it
has to be you know yeah it can't be
there must be something mental illness
or whatever what just like they cannot
fathom and if we look at most of the
killings in history that's been done
atheism leads I think it's not I think
it's Christianity or atheist number one
and then Islam is sixth in the line
meaning in history non-muslims have been
committing far greater atrocities than
Muslims could ever do but let's carry on
the website he also runs has a warning
about not claiming asylum in
Germany among the many questions
investigators will surely be wanting to
know why someone who opposes Islam
allegedly chose to unleash such Terror
on a Christmas Market and here is where
we need you guys to report this to off
let's listen again very carefully I
don't if you guys missed it there among
the many questions investigators will
surely be wanting to know why someone
who opposes Islam allegedly chose to
unleash such Terror on a Christmas
Market you can't make this up she's
basically saying how somebody who is
against Islam meaning the the the they
are saying that the very definition the
origins of Islam is violence it's
terrorism it's against humanity so how
could it be someone who fiercely opposes
listen carefully Islam could do an
atrocity they're basically saying anyone
that opposes Islam would never do such a
thing Islam is inherently evil barbaric
violent terrorism and whatever it's for
that matter so it does not make sense
that how could one that opposes Islam
during such at atrocity meaning it's as
if they are
negating the shootings that happen in M
shoo happen in America every week the
the the the grape rape whatever is
happen in India majority yes okay U the
pedophiles who go to these countries the
white middle-aged men who are going and
all doing all this cars kind of stuff
and all these other killing the S are
killing men women children Massac all
them laughing about it joking one all of
this no no no they don't exist people
that oppose Islam do not do evil Islam
is evil report to ofcom guys I'm going
to give you the details you have to
report to ofcom in let's see the
remaining this is direct violation okay
and mass reported the ofcom the
investigations of course started
immediately there were house searches in
his hometown in Borg um there is of
course a very close look at his online
profile which seems bizarrely
anti-islamic bizarrely anti-islamic
meaning n we need to ask some questions
here that's bizarrely anti-islamic I
mean no when he was supporting your
narrative he fine it wasn't bizarrely
anti-islamic it was fine he anti-islamic
islamophobe but now because he's carried
out attack it's like oh no sounds a bit
bizarre now he's he's a bit too
islamophobe he should be a little bit no
no no you are in denial you are in
denial you cannot fathom cuz you're like
no it has to be a Muslim it has to be a
Muslim it's not a Muslim no it doesn't
it doesn't add up you know it's like a
it's like a person who does his attacks
you know he has his moment and he goes
oh let me see yeah I'm meting un well
I've just become mentally unw we Muslims
we are prone we are immune to being
mentally we cannot be mentally unwi it's
is an impossibility for a Muslim to be
ment uhuh and antii um and rightwing um
so obviously they're trying to figure
out what precisely was going on the
attack comes amid heightened vigilance
at Christmas markets worldwide only this
week the British security minister
visited Shoppers in London to raise
awareness in a nsh with this part
they're basically saying you know even
though this was not a Muslim just so you
guys know there's heightened measures
across the board in the different
countries police are basically saying
we're expecting the Muslims to attack
any second so they're just telling you
there is still hope there is still hope
that a Muslim is going to carry the
attack so we can push our propaganda and
our agenda and forget about what Zionist
are doing the true criminals the true
evil people what they're doing to the
Palestinians so they here don't worry
you know they still heighten just keep
that there still you know it's still
heighten me don't ever think that it's
not going to be a Muslim it's still
going to be a Muslim we're going to get
to hate Islam it's not working those
days are over the majority of the people
they see they see the truth in Islam
they see it we have people flocking to
Islam so it's not working anymore people
have seen the real evildoers who are
doing false false flag attacks around
the world who have even attacked Navy
ships okay um a couple of decades ago
Zionist who attacked US Navy ships okay
so it's clear the whole world can see
who's behind what so carrying the
propaganda brother sisters report this
St that's all I wanted to say may Allah
bless you guys till next
time the prophet Sall alh wasallam said
whoever build and Masid for the sake of
Allah subhana tala Allah will build for
him a similar house in Jen on that day
where Allah subhana tal tells us that
our books will be given and every little
atam weight of Good Deed you've done
will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and you're like what a lucky
person which righteous person and Allah
says this is for you for me yes what did
I do you allowed people to pray you
built a Masjid I never had the money to
build a Masjid oh Allah you helped you
gave towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if you built it donate now
guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra Rewards
[Music]